as shells rained down Russia's Advance
on back moot is choking The Roots into
the city at the epicenter of this war
we traveled on one of the remaining
roads in
it is a sketchy nervous Journey along
smashed up streets
everywhere here is in the line of fire
and the casualties on both sides have
been staggering
it's clear this grueling fight is
morphing into urban combats
inside the city Ukrainian forces are
making fortifications
lines of Soviet era tanks and armored
vehicles are concealed amongst the
buildings
this city has become a symbolic prize
for Russia
although it appears to be of small
strategic value
it's pretty much deserted around here at
the moment there are a few civilians
over there a man
eating wood but most of these apartment
blocks have been damaged by shelling and
people have left the city it's very
unnerving
just being here but the fighting now is
very very close
there are still a few remaining people
who are trying to salvage their
belongings
those remaining are terrified but don't
know where else to go
foreign
[Music]
Ukrainian soldiers told us Russian
forces are now on the edge of the city
and they say they desperately need more
modern weapons if that has stopped
Vladimir Putin's Army in its tracks
we need weapons today because after
tomorrow this city can be destroyed
already and if we will be wait I can die
but I want to live and I want to support
my country if you wait
maybe Russian will be in Poland tomorrow
we can wait one month one year I don't
know how many time but if we can't stop
rushing now uh your army must stop
Russian tomorrow
is preparing for another massive Russian
offensive the soldiers here hope they
can resist but after the loss of the
nearby town of solidar they expect
another Relentless fight Alex Rossi Sky
News back moves